[Musique]
bonsoir c'est lors d'auditions publiques
sur lcp assemblée nationale public sénat
avec le figaro comme tous les lundis en
direct pendant une heure l'allocution
d'emmanuel macro hier soir c'était pas
encore l'acte iii du quinquennat mais la
phase iii du déconfinement retour à
l'école pour tout le monde ça a été l'un
des messages du président de la
république hier soir une mesure attendue
par les uns considérée comme un prétexte
pour les autres à quinze jours des
vacances scolaires
le président de république qui a promis
par ailleurs 1 1
un effort pour la jeunesse qui payent le
prix de la crise at il dit et on va
parler de tout cela ce soir avec notre
invité gabriela talent bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes secrétaire d'état à
l'éducation et à la jeunesse merci
d'être sur ce plateau où vont se
succéder pour vous interroger brigitte
boucher de lcp tam traduit de public
sénat et puis en duplex de
parlementaires qui ont leurs questions à
eux c'est cédric perrin sénateurs les
républicains du territoire de belfort et
jean michel clément député liberté
territoire de la vienne qui sont avec
nous ce soir et qu'on rejoindre à tout à
l'heure en duplex ils vous parleront
d'apprentissage par exemple ou des
libertés publiques
et puis carte blanche à la fin pour la
conclusion à yves thréard directeur
adjoint éditorialiste au figaro
d'abord les jeunes puisque c'est votre
dossier il y en a beaucoup dans les
manifestations on le voit ces dernières
semaines contre le racisme contre les
violences policières ce mouvement vous
surprend il ya un malaise chez une
partie de la jeunesse qui vient de loin
et d'ailleurs emmanuel macron dans la
campagne présidentielle en 2017 avait
mis des mots sur ce malaise
ce sentiment que moi je résume dans une
forme de société du deux poids deux
mesure où certains jeunes ont
l'impression qu'en raison du territoire
où ils brandissent qu'en raison parfois
leur couleur de peau ne connaisse pas le
même sort que les autres notamment en
termes d'accès à l'emploi d'accès au
logement parfois en termes de violence
dont ils peuvent faire faire faire
l'objet est finalement se cristallise
autour de cet enjeu beaucoup de choses
la question on l'a dit de venir avec la
police la question des discriminations
l'accès à l'emploi
au logement il nous appartient
d'apporter des aides mais je crois
beaucoup les dialogues ça vous surprend
je vous dis ça parce que imaginé il ya
quinze jours en plein confinement qui
aurait imaginé qu'il y aurait des
dizaines de milliers de jeunes parce qu
en particulier les jeunes dans la rue
autour de la famille traoré vous aurais
imaginé il ya eu un mais vous auriez il
ya une émotion mondiale autour du décès
de georges floyd we met ainsi en france
c'est adama très haut et bien sûr mais
on voit bien que c'est cet événement aux
états unis qui a entraîné légitimement
d'ailleurs une émotion au niveau mondial
et qui a remis l'accent sur
effectivement cette affaire autour du
décès tragique de adama traoré
encore une fois je ne suis pas surpris
dans le sens où on ne découvre pas qu'il
ya un malaise chez une partie de la
jeunesse et la question encore une fois
c'est d'y répondre mais la réponse n'a
pas été apportées depuis le début du
quinquennat depuis le début du
quinquennat on agit beaucoup sur saison
lui mais visiblement ça suffit
d'ailleurs il faut continuer il faut
aller parfois est ce que c est ce que
vous tirer une conclusion en disant ben
on a raté quelque chose vous savez on
est à trois ans du quinquennat il reste
deux années c'est des enjeux qui sont
extrêmement profonds et quelque chose à
vous hydrater une action de long terme
si vous si on pose cette question là il
faut la poser aux décennies qui viennent
de s'écouler on peut se mettre dedans
aussi évidemment et on voit bien qu'il
ya un enjeu autour de l'idéal
républicain de l'égal accès aux chances
y compris dans la question du rapport
d'une partie des jeunes avec la police
est ce que vous craignez une révolte de
la jeunesse
non moi je ne les dit récemment dans une
interview moi je je crois au pacifisme
de ma génération je pense profondément
que je fais partie d'une génération un
pacifique se mobilisent pour défendre
des causes
on l'a vu au tour du climat on le voit
aujourd'hui régionaux l'aveu de jeunesse
à mai 68 en 2020 ça peut pas exister non
mais encore une fois ce qui m'inquiète
c'est que des personnes parfois politisé
cherchent à utiliser ce malaise est
utilisé ce débat pour faire toujours été
pour faire vivre aux jeunes pour faire
prospérer des thèses qui sont
séparatistes qui sont communautaristes
on l'a vu on le voit du côté des
indigènes is on le voit du côté des
insoumis on ne voit du côté de marion
maréchal-le pen qui a pris la parole ce
week-end pour la première fois depuis un
certain temps parce qu'elle sent qu'il
ya ce climat de malaise et qu'elle peut
faire prospérer
là dessus les justement vision vous
mettez un signe égal entre les a soumis
lundi
in east 10 k oui enfin je pense qu'il ya
des insoumis qui prospectent font
prospérer ses thèses là on voit dans le
rang qui sont des thèses indigéniste qui
encore une fois prospère sur le malaise
de certains jeunes en leur disant
finalement vous vous sentez discriminés
en raison de votre couleur de peau en
raison de votre origine à la verse
également vous faites
connaissez-vous dedans en priorité et
moi je parle ce que voudrait un
rapprochement al'inverse entre marine le
pen et génération identitaire enfin je
le vois bien que beaucoup cherchent à
faire prospérer leurs thèses politiques
et leurs intérêts politiques dans cette
affaire là ils ont des intérêts qui sont
parfois différents mais en tout cas on
voit bien quelle cette offensive là et
je pense qu'il faut prendre garde
on va cueillir maintenant brigitte
boucher de lcp assemblée nationale
[Musique]
bonsoir francis bonsoir gabriela talent
on commence tout de suite avec l'école
qui va reprendre dans une semaine c'est
ce que nous a dit le président de la
république
hier soir donc pour les écoles pour les
collèges de façon obligatoire
est-ce que vous pensez que 100% des
enfants pourront être accueillis à temps
plein sur c'est l'engagement qu'a pris
le président de la république et avec
jean michel blanquer on est en train de
tout faire pour accueillir les enfants à
partir de là dedans plein champ à temps
plein des journées complètes des
semaines complètes mais c'est le
l'engagement qui a été pris par le
président il ya quand même un protocole
sanitaire qui existe un maître latérale
entre chaque enfant ces nouveaux
protocoles contre 4 mètres carrés
auparavant ça veut dire qu'on pourra
faire rentrer dans une classe de 30
élèves par exemple l'ensemble des
enfants alors le passage on passe d'un
protocole sanitaire à un autre il ya un
protocole sanitaire nouveau qui va être
publié demain je crois il ya un décret
qui est sorti aujourd'hui effectivement
il ya un grand changement c'est qu'on
passe d'une distance de 4 mètres carrés
autour de l'élève à une distance d'un
mètre latérale entre les élèves ce qui
va permettre de faire revenir beaucoup
plus d'enfants tous les enfants
s'adaptant au niveau local avec
pragmatisme là où c'est nécessaire
alors hier parmi les mesures annoncées
celle sur l'école a le moins convaincu
c'est un sondage opinionway pour les
échos qui nous le dit comment vous
l'expliquez alors j'ai pas vu ce sont
tombés il ya une heure c'est à dire le
tout des mesures qui ont été prises sont
à gré du temps dépensée à 60,81 pour
l'école ça n'est qu'à 50 majorité et moi
je vous avais je suis secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale est depuis plusieurs semaines
je reçois beaucoup de messages et dans
mes déplacements je rencontre beaucoup
des cadrans qui me disant qu'ils
souhaitent que leurs enfants puissent
rejoindre à aider quand vous voyez
qu'est ce qui se passe et comment vous
l'expliquez on vous savez il y avait des
doutes quand le président de la
république a annoncé la réouverture
progressive des écoles 11 mai on se
souvient l'époque des débats qui a eu
beaucoup de personnes nous disait des
scientifiques d'ailleurs mais pas
uniquement des responsables politiques
des français nous disent est ce que vous
prenez pas un risque trop important
est ce que finalement il ne s'est pas
risqué on regarde la situation sanitaire
et on a été beaucoup plus critiqué que
soutenu à ce goût là les doutes ne sont
pas levés maman d'un petit on a réussi à
convaincre sauf que visiblement non là
on a réussi à lever ce que mon nom quand
vous regardez les sondages les choses
ont quand même beaucoup beaucoup mais
visiblement et moi je suis là pour aider
il ya encore des doutes mais je suis
persuadé que ceux qui doutent seront
convaincus la semaine prochaine quand
ils verront que tout l'été vous pourriez
comprendre que des parents hésitent à
remettre leurs enfants à l'école qu' ils
hésitent parce qu'il me faisait peur
d'un risque sanitaire éventuellement
voit bien qu'il ya des inquiétudes
depuis le départ y compris le 11 mai
quand on a rouvert déjà y avait des
inquiétudes
moi j'entends les inquiétudes notre
enjeu c'est d'y répondre moi je suis
persuadé que la période qu'on vient de
vivre avec le début du déconfinement des
écoles si on l'appelle comme ça a permis
de montrer que tous les garanties était
donné en termes de sécurité sanitaire
pour les enfants est précisément si on a
un nouveau protocole sanitaire avec des
règles de distanciation qui demeurent
des règles d'hygiène qui demeure c'est
aussi pour assurer la sefa ni pour poser
la question différemment qu'est ce que
vous diriez à des parents qui ne veulent
pas envoyer leurs enfants à l'école mais
je leur dirai que c'est bon pour leurs
enfants de retourner à l'école je leur
dirais que c'est vous les envoyez bien
sûr je leur dirais que c'est important
d'abord pour cadre un risque pour
apprendre il n'y a pas de risque
puisqu'on prend on met en place des
mesures concertées avec les autorités
sanitaires pour garantir qu'il n'y ait
pas de risque et je dirais aussi que
c'est important pour préparer la rentrée
c'est important que les écoliers se
remettent dans cette culture de l'école
c'est important aussi en prévision de
deux jusqu'à présent l'école était
considéré comme facultative pendant le
confinement en tout cas et
à la sortie du confinement plus tôt est
ce que finalement c'était un peu le
péché originel est ce que c'était une
erreur de considérer que l'école n'était
pas obligatoire la sortie du confinement
comme elle l'est non là dessus je pense
qu'à une ambiguïté sémantique puisque
l'instruction est obligatoire
le retour physique à l'école était se
faisait vite sur la base du volontariat
et moi j'assume parfaitement je pense
que c'était nécessaire de le faire aussi
parce qu'il y avait des inquiétudes
maintenant on voit bien que l'on
l'objectif c'est d'accueillir tous les
élèves
évidemment quand les enfants ne
retournez pas à l'école dans cette
période intermedia il y avait la
continuité pédagogique
ils étaient tenus de continuer à
apprendre depuis chez eux ce qui était
parfois très d'éprouvants pour les
parents et parfois beaucoup de parents
on était fatigués de cette situation
surtout s'il était en même temps en
télétravail depuis chez eux
donc c'est important que les enfants
puissent retourner à l'école massivement
l'idée aussi c'était que les décrocheurs
puissent être accueillis à l'école
l'association france urbaine au qui
représente les maires des grandes villes
nous dit que 5% des enfants des
quartiers défavorisés sont retournés à
l'école seulement 5%
et est ce que vous considérez que c'est
un échec finalement que vous n'avez pas
réussi à faire revenir les décrocheurs
mais je pense que la semaine prochaine
sera un moment clé pour la question des
décrocheurs c'est vrai qu'il ya des
enfants qui qu'on a perdu des radars au
début du confinement
ce sera l'occasion de voir si la doyenne
ou pas c'était autour de 10% au début du
confinement d'enfance on n'avait plus de
nouvelles
il ya une mobilisation exceptionnelle de
la part des enseignants à distance pour
aller chercher ses enfants en lien avec
des associations des élus locaux et
progressivement tout au long du
confinement le nombre d'enfants qui
étaient entre guillemets en rade à ccc
réduit on était à 4% vient de ce que
vous avez dit leur grille au théâtre
c'est que finalement lundi prochain ce
sera l'heure de vérité c'est là qu'on
verra si les décrocheurs reviennent pas
non ce que je dis c'est que il faut
qu'ils reviennent lundi près d'accord
bce sera l'heure de vérité lundi oui
bien sûr il y aura une forme il y aura
une forme d'art de vérité mais encore
une fois c'est bon pour les enfants
c'est bon pour leur apprentissage c'est
bon pour leur vie dans un collectif et
que 5% des décrocheurs qui sont venus
pendant le confinement c'est quand même
un échec comme je n'ai pas cette france
urbaine
on s'est déjà fait confiance aussi
on voit bien le dire il faut être lucide
et où le péché originel peut-être delà
du côté facultatif de l'école non je ne
crois pas vous savez c'est un équilibre
très difficile à tenir entre d'un côté
la volonté de rassurer
les familles il y a eu des familles il
ya encore des familles très inquiète
face à la situation sanitaire
de l'autre côté la possibilité pour les
enfants de continuer leur apprentissage
c'est peut-être des enfants qui
bénéficient de la continuité pédagogique
et avait un lien avec leurs enseignants
leurs enseignants à distance depuis chez
eux là on parler d'école privée à
l'opposé de l'école publique à l'opposé
dans le privé on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait beaucoup plus d'enfants
qui étaient accueillis dans les écoles
est ce qu'elles ont pris un risque
finalement c'est ces écoles privées
écoutez je ne dirais pas ça je dirais
pas ça il ya eu un moment des débats sur
la question du protocole sanitaire et je
crois que les choses ont été assez vite
clarifier avec avec jean michel blanquer
moi ce que j'ai vu c'est une
mobilisation de l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative que ce soit dans le
public ou dans le privé pour l'intérêt
des enfants
est ce que c'est ça qui compte à la fin
c'est l'intérêt des enfants nous a
beaucoup accusé de vouloir ouvrir les
écoles pour des motifs économiques
ensuite on nous a dit que l'on allait
rouvrir vous avez pas assez vite nous la
seule boussole ce qui nous guide c'est
l'intérêt de l'enfant et l'intérêt de
l'enfant il y avait de retourner à
l'école n'y a pas de différence entre le
privé et le public de ce point de vue je
ne crois pas je ne crois pas jean michel
blanquer sera mieux vous répondre que
moi mais je ne crois pas cette rentrée
qui aura lieu donc à partir de lundi
obligatoire pour tous les enfants
elle se fait finalement à quinze jours
des vacances d'été de l'arrêt de l'école
pour l'année scolaire
est-ce que c'est pas pour obliger
finalement les enseignants reprendre le
chemin de l'école on sait que certains
tard et traînent des pieds non moi là
dessus je veux vraiment qu'on arrête
avec le prof bashing
les enseignants ont été extrêmement
mobilisés pendant confinement et c'était
pas facile parfois depuis chez eux quand
eux-mêmes avaient des enfants chez eux
avec leur ordinateur personnel et
parfois des équipements qui était pas
toujours présent pour faire le lien avec
les élèves
il y en a qui ont vraiment mais fait
preuve d'une inventivité exceptionnelle
pour réussir à toucher des élèves
éloignés ou ou décrocheurs comme ceux
qu'on évoquait il ya une mobilisation un
sauf que ces gens michel leclerc qui a
parlé des profs décrocheurs non mais
dans toute organisation 5% entre un
décrocheur dit jean michel blondeau
vieux prof bashing le professeur ben non
ça je te laisse urgent d'y aller mourir
là chaque fois qu'ils s'expriment
rappelle que l'essentiel des enseignants
la quasi totalité des enseignants a été
parfaitement mobilise m'en faudrait
peut-être pas pointer du doigt la
minorité vous éviterez ne pointe pas du
doigt on ne fonde pas du doigt il ya
dans toute organisation collective ce
soit l'entreprise ce soit dans une
administration en l'occurrence ici
l'éducation nationale il peut toujours y
avoir des pertes il y aura sanction si
jamais ces profs décrocheurs ne sont pas
là lundi prochain mais jean michel
blanquer a déjà eu l'occasion de dire
qui aurait des sanctions pour ceux qui
ne se présenterait pas sans motif
valable vous savez que il ya une raison
de ne pas revenir quand on est
enseignant c'est si on est vulnérable et
qu'on a des facteurs de vulnérabilité
notamment des maladies chroniques des
maladies lourdes vis-à-vis du coc vide à
ce moment-là avec un certificat médial
un droit de retrait sinon non mais un
certificat médical qui justifie vous ne
pouvez pas le droit de retrait ce cas de
retrait non il n'y a pas de droit de
retrait il ya une possibilité pour des
percées des personnels qui sont
vulnérables avec un certificat médical
de ne pas retourner travailler juste
quand vous parlez du professeur bashing
du prof de gym j'ai vu comment vous
dédie qui fait ce prof de shing bas on a
vu un beau coup sur les réseaux sociaux
des personnes qui prenaient position
alors c'est quand vous dit non mais je
pense que beaucoup de personnes à des
opposants politiques foot jeux jeux non
j'ai pas d'exemple de responsables
politiques mais y compris voilà dans
l'est dans les médias parfois on a
beaucoup entendu sujet si jean-michel
bancaire s'est exprimé sur cette
question c'était pas pour pointer du
doigt c'est parce qu'il répondait à des
questions qui lui étaient posées qui
pointait elle-même du doigt c'est très
baveux où ça a été posé la question s'il
n'y a pas de deuxième vague de cette
épidémie de kovy de 19
est-ce que l'école pourra reprendre
normalement au mois de septembre
ou est-ce que certaines règles
continueront à s'appliquer par principe
on va s'adapter à la situation sanitaire
fait aujourd'hui si on maintient un
protocole sanitaire dans les écoles
c'est parce qu'on maintient des
protocoles sanitaires dans les
entreprises dans l'ensemble des
établissements qui reçoivent du public
donc il en sera de même pour l'école à
la rentrée
je suis incapable de vous dire ce que
sera la situation sanitaire à la rentrée
ça reste ouvert
oui ce que je peux vous dire en revanche
c'est que la mobilisation on est en
train de mener pour accueillir tous les
enfants à partir du 22 juin
c'est la fin nous mènerons la même
mobilisation pour accueillir tous les
enfants à la rentrée demain cela vous
dit brigitte c'est que si il n'y a pas
de deuxième vague est ce qu'on gardera
quand même des critères sanitaires
il y aura quand même les gestes barrière
est un maître latéral ça c'est une
question qui se pose pour l'ensemble des
établissements recevant du public et
pour l'ensemble de la vie collective
mouallem au moins septembre si la
condition et les conditions sanitaires
s'améliore en fonction des conditions
sanitaires en septembre on voit bien que
les choses s'améliorent très fortement
ministre de la santé a dit ce matin que
le koro de l'épidémie était derrière
nous si on progresse dans cette
direction au cours de l'été en prendre
acte et il y aura une décision qui sera
prise à ce moment là au regard de la
situation qu'on connaîtra sur scène en
revanche si à l'automne ya une deuxième
vague est ce qu'on fermera comme pour la
première
toutes les écoles où est ce qu'on fera
du cas par cas c'est évidemment très
compliqué pour moi de vous répondre ce
que je peux vous dire en revanche c'est
que je crois qu'on a beaucoup appris de
la période qui s'est déroulée par
principe ce qu'on a vécu est
parfaitement est totalement inédit
jamais notre pays avait connu une telle
situation et la décision qu'on a prise
de confiner le pays
juste avant de fermer l'ensemble des
établissements scolaires étaient
inédites et moi ce sur quoi je vais
insister c'est que on a été très réactif
la france est le pays qui a mis en place
le plus rapidement un système de
continuité pédagogique parce qu'il se
trouve que jean-michel bancaire avait
travaillé sur ce sujet depuis deux ans
suite à l'ouragan rma ou dans un certain
nombre de territoires ultramarins les
écoles avaient dû être fermées et où on
avait mis en place une plateforme
pédagogique et c'est ce qui nous a
permis dès le lendemain du confinement
de mettre en place cette continuité
confinement salaires la réponse
généralisée vous imaginez ça à l'école
une nouvelle fois ça ferait le deuxième
année scolaire rate c'est envisageable
je ne peux pas m'exprimer sur la mairie
sur ce qui relève du cas par cas ce
serait mieux mais par principe
encore une fois on a appris de la
période qui s'est écoulée et on fera au
mieux
merci brigitte merci gabriel atteint on
va rejoindre maintenant vincent roux qui
nous attendent depuis la salle de
rédaction du figaro live et qui suit
exactement tout ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité et ce qui fait écho dans
l'actualité auprès des internautes et
des lecteurs et des internautes du
figaro live vincent qu est ce qui
ressort ce soir ce qui ressort ce soir
bonsoir francis bonsoir gabriela talent
beaucoup de commentaires sur les
affrontements de ce week end à dijon
entre ressortissants tchétchènes et
maghrébins des beaucoup de commentaires
les sur les scènes de d'extrême violence
qui circule sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui ont sidéré littéralement un certain
nombre d'internautes qui sont en colère
les communautés étrangères règlent leurs
contentieux sur le territoire français
peut-on lire société multiplié
multiculturelle égale sulte société
multi conflictuelle s'emporte un autre
surréaliste y at il encore quelqu'un
capable de tenir les rênes en france
c'est ce que demande un internaute
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez lui répondre
gabriel à ta maman est ce que je peux
lui répondre d'abord c'est que je trouve
comme lui que ces images sont sidérantes
est choquant sur fond de trafic de
drogue oui mais c'est des images qui
sont extrêmement choquantes extrêmement
violente une fois que vous avez dit ça
une fois que j'ai dit ça
ce que je peux dire c'est que il ya une
mobilisation très forte des services de
police et de gendarmerie localement je
crois qu'il y avait hier demi compagnie
de crs 37 policiers qui étaient là des
renforts de la bac et que sans doute si
tous ces policiers n'avaient pas été là
les choses auraient pu être encore pire
il ya une enquête qui est en cours
et évidemment elle va suivre son cours
et elle donnera lieu à des
interpellations
moi ce que je veux dire c'est que dans
le contexte c'est aussi un rappel de ce
que c'est aujourd'hui l'exercice du
métier de policier est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui des difficultés auxquelles
nos policiers font face sur le terrain
c'est-à-dire une parfois une très grande
une très grande violence et mais en même
temps voyez que ça se passe dans des
dans un quartier de dijon quartiers
sensibles
là aussi pour ramener à votre dossier
qui est la jeunesse il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui vivent dans ces quartiers
quel est l'avenir de ici dans ces
quartiers oui on agit énormément pour la
jeunesse des quartiers depuis 2017 on
voit bien que on en revient à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure
alors moi je veux pas faire de lien
immédiat entre le malaise l'accès à
l'emploi et des faits criminels qui sont
d'une incroyable gravité qui ne peuvent
faire l'objet d'aucune justification
aucune excuse donc ces deux sujets qui
sont différents si vous me posez la
question de savoir quelle est la
perspective qu'on donne aux jeunes dans
les quartiers il ya une perspective très
forte qui est celle de l'éducation est
doublement des classes en ré paieraient
plus c'est des millions d'élèves qui
sont dans des classes plus petites avec
la possibilité d'être mieux accompagnée
c'est l'emploi avec les emplois francs
pour permettre aux entreprises qui
recrutent déjà là à s'exercer dans ces
trafics de drogue qui fait la loi à la
en l'occurrence c'est une situation qui
est absolument inacceptable
et encore une fois qui fera le blog
l'objet d'une réponse absolument ferme
merci vincent
on va maintenant accueillir thème tran
huy de public sénat
[Musique]
bon sur table bonsoir francis monsois
gabriela talent on va continuer à parler
de cette jeunesse je t'ai ce qui est
très impacté par la crise du coc vide
hier emmanuel macron a parlé d'un
investissement massif pour la jeunesse
là on a déjà eu les mesures en matière
d'apprentissage quoi d'autre oui alors
c'est important de rappeler les mesures
en matière d'apprentissage parce que
c'est pour nous essentiel on les a eus
permettez quelques instants de dire
l'apprentissage c'est une voie sur
laquelle on a décidé d'investir depuis
trois ans parce que c'est une voie
royale pour les jeunes pour trouver un
emploi et c'est une voie essentielle
pour les entreprises pour bénéficier de
jeunes qui sont formés cas le message
mais quad et ce sont des métiers et donc
c'était très important que la dynamique
qu'on a engagée l'an dernier il ya eu
presque 500 mille jeunes en
apprentissage une augmentation de 16 %
qu'elles ne seront pas et donc les
mesures qui ont été annoncées c'est
important de le rappeler nous regarder
ce problème c'est un milliard d'euros
c'est à dire une aide à l'embauché
d'apprentis pour les entreprises qui va
jusqu'à 8000 euros donc très
concrètement pour les envers les risques
mais que ça ne vous trouve maintenant
maintenant je travaille à la demande du
président du premier ministre en lien
avec muriel pénicaud avec bruno le maire
avec jean michel blanquer
sur un plan plus global sur la question
de la jeunesse face à la crise et on a
plusieurs priorités
vous allez l'annoncé bientôt ce plan je
vais faire remonter mais proposition
offrait le ministère du président ils
sont on a plusieurs priorités on a
d'abord une priorité qui est de lutter
contre le décrochage en tout cas
permettre que les jeunes notamment dans
la voie professionnelle scolaire et dans
l'apprentissage qui ont décroché à
l'occasion du confinement puisse
raccrocher avec leur enseignement parce
que c'est absolument essentiel
un exemple cet été on va laisser ouvert
des lycées professionnels première
quinzaine de juillet dernière quinzaine
d'août pour accueillir des jeunes durant
l'été pour leur permettre de raccrocher
première chose deuxième objectif c'est
l'apprentissage des mesures ont été déjà
troisième objectif c'est la question de
l'accès à l'emploi des jeunes il ya 700
mille jeunes qui devraient entrer sur le
marché du travail septembre cette année
et moi j'entends parfaitement que ces
jeunes sont inquiets que leurs parents
leurs grands parents
d'où une question de la parlementaire
toutes sont inquiets alors on y
reviendra peut-être leur mandat il ya
des mesures très fortes à prendre sur ce
sujet et puis il ya un enjeu dont la
précarité de la jeunesse on sait que
c'est un enjeu pour
beaucoup de jeunes salle était déjà de
confinement a accru la précarité pour
une partie des jeunes c'est pour ça
qu'on a mis en place oui je le rappelais
une aide exceptionnelle de 200 euros
pour les jeunes qui ont connu une
précarité du fait du confinement ouidah
- il faut capitale on vous avait
commencé à parler de l'apprentissage
effectivement il ya une aide de 5000 à
8000 euros pour les entreprises qui
embauchent des jeunes des stagiaires des
apprentis qui font de l'alternance mais
cela seulement jusqu'à la licence
oui pourquoi pas ce qu'il faut pas
étendre cette aide au delà au niveau
master c'est une demande un certain
nombre d'universités note ainsi un choix
qu'on a fait d'aller jusqu'à la licence
professionnelle ce qui a donné un champ
quand même très large et pourquoi pas
besoin de l'apprentissage parce qu'il a
été considéré c'est dans la paix nico
qui a mené ce travail que c'est à ce
niveau de qualification qu' il y avait
le plus de risques en matière de rupture
pour les entreprises qui était qui était
concerné donc c'est assumer autre
proposition celle de l air qui a proposé
d'exonérer de charges pendant deux ans
les entreprises qui embauchent des
jeunes
c'était une proposition de loi que la
république en marche a rejeté est ce que
vous le regrettez à ce que sur le
principe ça va dans le bon sens moi je
pense que il faut qu'on regarde toutes
les propositions et la question des
jeunes la question de l'accès à l'emploi
des jeunes pour moi c'est un vrai sujet
de rassemblement y compris de
rassemblement politique parce que à la
cera grande cause nationale et oui mais
est-ce que ça l'important c'est toutes
les propositions soient étudiées je vais
vous dire étudiée mais un joli mais je
vais vous dire pourquoi l'on pourquoi
elle n'a pas été retenue parce qu'on
considère que ce n'est pas le moyen le
plus efficace de soutenir l'emploi des
jeunes pourquoi parce que cette
proposition elle vise à dire on exonère
de charges patronales les entreprises
qui recrutent un jeune la majorité
aujourd'hui des jeunes sont recrutés à
un niveau de salaire qui est proche du
smic qui est légèrement au dessus du
smic
les charges sur ses niveaux de salaires
sont déjà quasi intégralement supprimées
donc nous on considère qu' il ya des
manières plus son maintien et rétif ya
des manières plus ambitieuse encore de
soutenir l'emploi des jeunes ya
plusieurs pistes sur la table je pense
par exemple à une prime à l'embauché
un peu comme ce qu'on fait sur
l'apprentissage et c'est tout ça qui est
en train d'être regardé je rappelle qu'à
une consultation avec les partenaires
sociaux qui en cours avec muriel
pénicaud
vous avez commencé à parler de la
précarité un des jeunes pendant la crise
du coc vide les étudiants ont l'avion
étaient particulièrement vulnérables aux
niveaux aussi bien matériels qu au
niveau psychique
ça a été un moment très difficile pour
eux à passer est ce qu'il ya un plan
d'action prévu
alors destination d'abord je veux
rappeler qu' il ya des étudiants
effectivement qui ont connu une
précarité supplémentaires dans
confinement donne deux exemples ils
étaient les étudiants d'outre-mer qui
effectuent leurs études dans l'hexagone
qui par définition n'ont pas pu se
reposer sur une solidarité familiale
comme c'est le cas pour les jeunes
l'hexagone qui était loin et puis des
jeunes qui ont du mal à joindre les deux
bouts qui ont perdu leur job qui ont
perdu leur job ou qui ont l'habitude par
exemple de se nourrir au restaurant
universitaire à moindre coût les
restaurants universitaires étaient
fermés fallait aller faire les courses
au supermarché ça coûte plus cher c'est
le constat est là je l'avais vu plus
haut désormais déjà ce que je veux
indiquer c'est qu'on a mis en place une
aide de 200 euros pour ces jeunes oui
pour limiter l'impact sur la trésorerie
et que je travaille en ce moment avec ma
collègue frédéric vidal à des mesures
supplémentaires pour la rentrée pour les
jeunes qui seront autour de l'époque à
la finance et à l'harmonie arrêter ça
peut être avant fait régulière des aides
financières les bourses on regarde tous
les sujets mais ça peut être un
renforcement des aides d'urgence des
universités par exemple on va regarder
aussi la situation des jeunes qui ont
l'habitude d'être saisonniers l'été
oui alex et environ un tiers des jeunes
qui ont l'habitude normalement de
travailler l'été pour mettre un peu de
sou de côté pour ensuite tenir ce
justement là n'était saisonniers et bien
ils vont pas pouvoir travailler a
manifestement cette année et ces jeunes
et bien ils n'ont pas le droit au rsa
vous êtes toujours contre le rsa pour
les 18 25 ans malgré cette situation qu
on vous décrit alors d'abord
premièrement parce que je veux dire par
rapport à la première partie de votre
question c'est qu'il y a des
opportunités cet été pour travailler et
c'est important de le dire ou
s'installer sur le site de pôle emploi
il ya des offres qui sortent tous les
jours deux saisonniers dans l'hôtellerie
dans la restauration parce que
heureusement le déconfinement fait que
l'activité reprend ensuite c'est bien
mais c'est vrai qu'on prend pas trois
mais bon j'espère que je vivrai je vais
venir mais je veux quand même insisté
sur ce point là il ya les secteurs de
l'animation on a un plan massif pour les
colonies de vacances on en parlera
peut-être oui on a besoin d'animateurs
on a besoin de dix mille animateurs qui
n'ont pas pu être formé au moment du
confinement
ça fait des perspectives et les
perspectives dans le secteur agricole
aussi ils ont lancé un appel donc il ya
des perspectives pour les jeunes
maintenant il ya des jeunes qui
peut-être ont l'habitude de travailler
qui ne pourront travailler cet été là la
question c'est l'accompagnement
financier wii via les universités à la
rentrée mois pour revenir à votre
question est intéressant pour moi il n'y
a pas de débat sur le fait de savoir
s'il faut accompagner les jeunes y
compris financièrement quand ils sont
dans la précarité quand ils sont dans
des situations de rupture
il a logé sa compagne
ils doivent être accompagnés la question
c'est comment et moi je considère que le
est d'étendre le rsa aux moins de 25 ans
n'est pas la meilleure solution
d'abord parce que ceux qui défendent
l'extension du rsa aux moins de 25 ans
dont stanislas guérini patron des
patrons des grands marchés c'est
important d'avancer des idées de
débattre il n'y a pas de y'a pas de
problème là-dessus mais ceux qui
défendent cette idée là pour la finance
et propose de revenir pour les parents
sur leur demi-part fiscale liée à leur
enfant et donc d'augmenter les impôts
des parents nous on s'est engagé à ne
pas augmenter les impôts ça c'est la
première raison est la deuxième raison
c'est que je pense qu'on peut faire
mieux que ça on a aujourd'hui des
dispositifs je pense à la garantie
jeunes je pense aux pacéens qui sont
gérés par les missions locales qui
permettent d'accompagner les jeunes en
matière avec un accompagnement humain
qui leur père qui leur propose des
modules de formation des stages en
milieu professionnel avec un
accompagnement financier qui est de
l'ordre du rsa qui est autour de 500
euros mais avec en face de la formation
du travail c'est à dire pas une activité
pas juste de l'argent comme toi mon
objectif si vous voulez pour les jeunes
qui chercheraient un emploi qui n'en
trouverai pas ou pour les jeunes qui
seraient qui aurait décroché c'est
évidemment les accompagner
financièrement quand ils sont dans des
situations de rupture mais c'est aussi
de leur proposer une activité et une
ligne en plus sur leur cv si on ne vous
parle pas de rsa sans rien avec ses sacs
vont alourdir une contrepartie vous êtes
aussi en charge vous l'avez dit un des
centres aérés et les colonies de
vacances est-ce que et bien ses cendres
ont pouvoir accueillir autant d'enfants
que l'année dernière d'abord alors il ya
une grosse mobilisation avec les
colonies de vacances est ce qu'il veut y
voir autant d'enfants accueillis cas
l'année dernière
bah ça où on verra ce que décident les
familles moi je lance un magnum et les
capacités d'en accueillir autant que
l'année dernière
bien sûr on a mis en place un protocole
sanitaire qu'on a travaillé avec eux qui
est très clair qui est très concis et
qui a été à travailler avec les grandes
organisations du secteur pour faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent ramener environ
100 sanitaires mais ce sont les mêmes
que celles de l'école avec le maître
latéral sais pas c'est pas tout à fait
la même situation parce qu'il ya un
hébergement mais oui après ça dépend des
activités
il n'y a pas de port du masque
obligatoire sauf dans les cas où les
jeunes avec les animateurs sera confiné
dans un lieu clos ce qui n'arrive pas
souvent dans le cadre d'une colonie de
vacances et on a eu un vrai travail
notables on est allé jusque dans les
détails du lit superposé qui sont
autorisés avec des mesures qui
permettent de garantir la sécurité jean
fauque cyclosport envoyer vos enfants
n'y a pas de risque oui je dis aux
familles que les enfants et les jeunes
ont vécu un moment difficile avec le
confinement où ils sont restés chez eux
et que le fait de pouvoir s'aérer de
pouvoir s'évader de pouvoir quitter son
environnement immédiat d'être au contact
d'autres jeunes et de s'épanouir
c'est absolument essentiel aujourd'hui
cet été pour respirer et on va mettre en
est on met en place un plan massif pour
financer le départ en colonie de
vacances de deux cent cinquante mille
jeunes ses vacances doivent être des
vacances apprenantes ce sont les mots de
jean michel blanquer les vacances après
nantes c'est quoi exactement
sont visés il ya un million d'enfants
défavorisés notamment les vacances
apprenantes c'est l'idée d'avoir des
vacances je fais j'insiste beaucoup
là-dessus pour les enfants nous met des
gaules en même temps qui permette de
s'aérer d'être ludique mais avec un
certain nombre d'enseignements qui sont
transmis qui correspondent à des
enseignements qui ont été manqués ou qui
n'ont pas été transmis par qui vous
aurez des enseignants qui seront devant
les marques on va mobiliser des
animateurs à qui on va fournir et
compris des modules qui ont été
travaillés avec l'éducation nationale
les enseignants danse éveil avoir des
enseignants volontaires bien sûr que si
dans le m haies mais ce sera surtout les
animateurs vous donne un exemple met en
place un différend force un dispositif
qui s'appelle l'école ouverte
c'est la première quinzaine de juillet
dernière quinzaine d'août on laisse des
établissements scolaires ouverts
vous avez des cours le matin et l'après
midi vous avez des activités culturelles
et sportives
ce espère accueillir 400 milles à 100%
et à la terminale espérer 70 mille l'an
dernier et faire revenir des des
enseignants pour cette période de
vacances alors que déjà on arrivait
cette difficulté sur l'épreuve
décrocheurs mais vous savez il ya une
tradition très fort dans l'éducation
nationale de lien avec l'éducation
populaire qui d'enseignants qui sont
très liés à des mouvements d'éducation
populaire et qui se mobilisent y compris
sur une partie de leur été
pour accompagner des enfants il ya eu
par ailleurs une rémunération en plus de
leur rémunération pour les journées oui
s'accompagnait de 70000 à 400 mille
enfants c'est quand même un sacré
challenge c'est très ambitieux mais
c'est enfin on se doit d'être ambitieux
pour nos jeunes et pour nos enfants
c'est tt dernière question ou une
dernière question sur et bien le débat
qui s'ouvre sur les statistiques
ethniques votre collègue cib et ndèye
propose bien
ouvrir justement ce débat emmanuel
macron dit que ce n'est pas le moment
est ce que pour vous il faut ouvrir ce
débat est ce que vous êtes favorable aux
statistiques ethniques
alors moi par principe il me semble
légitime que chacun puisse faire des
propositions et surtout en cette période
où sans que ces enjeux là sont très fort
en moi à titre personnel je suis pas
favorable et précisément s'il y avait un
débat je pourrais peut-être entendre des
arguments dans un sens ou dans l'autre
je suis pas totalement favorable parce
que quand on en parle on fait souvent
référence aux états unis où il ya cette
pratique depuis maintenant plusieurs
décennies et ses objectifs et la
situation oui j'ai bien aimé mais
précisément on voit que aujourd'hui il
ya de vrais problèmes aux états unis
notre odeur favorable parce que parce
que pour l'instant je n'ai pas d'exemple
qui permettent de montrer que dans un
pays ça a permis de répondre à l'enjeu
et ensuite parce que moi je me bats pour
que on dit aux français et notamment aux
jeunes puisque chez en charge de la
jeunesse qui sont français avant tout
qu'ils doivent avoir les mêmes droits
que les autres parce qu'ils sont
français avant tout et ma crainte c'est
que dans les statistiques ethniques
finalement on accrédite cette idée qu'il
faut qu'ils s'identifient comme autre
chose avant d'aller ne sont pas 100 %
français voilà merci tam
merci beaucoup une dernière question
avant de rejoindre les parlementaires
vous êtes responsable du service
national universel
cette année il ya dix mille jeunes qui
sont attendus au service national
universel ça va être maintenue ça c'est
dit milou est ce que du fait des
circonstances ça va être abaissé ça sera
maintenue le service national universel
y vise à donner à la jeunesse de france
à voir toutes les possibilités
d'engagement pour servir son pays
et cette année on a peut-être encore
plus besoin que les autres années de
jeunes qui s'engagent pour leur pays on
a vu les jeunes du service civique très
mobilisés pendant le confinement et donc
dix mille jeunes ce sera maintenue à
partir du 4 juillet
c'est dix mille jeunes cette veine plus
à l'origine feront une mission d'intérêt
général auprès d'associations prêtre
corps en uniforme
il a identifié trois grandes causes la
question des personnes âgées liens
intergénérationnels
la question de l'environnement qui est
très cher aux jeunes et puis la question
de la solidarité pour les plus
vulnérables qui liront s'engager pendant
quinze jours et puis ensuite il y aura
le séjour de cohésion encadrés par des
militaires des associatifs que j'espère
pouvoir organiser à l'automne que vous
espérez c'est pas sûr évidemment on
s'adaptera la condition si c'était le
cas on trouvera ce serait une génération
sacrifiée non il n'y aura pas de
génération sacrifiée y compris pour le
service national universel à des
aménagements les jeunes qui s'engagent
la mission d'intérêt général en juillet
feront un séjour de cohésion c'est un
engagement que je prends
il y aura de toute façon ce séjour de
cohésion quoi qu'il en soit on va
rejoindre maintenant nos parlementaires
donc et bonsoir à cédric perrin qui est
sénateur les républicains de territoire
de belfort bonsoir à vous et bonsoir
aussi avoue jean-michel clément qui est
député liberté territoire de la vienne
ancien la république en marge liée au
passage on va commencer par vous parce
que la première question vous souhaitez
poser au ministre c'est à propos des
libertés oui écouter oui effectivement
la question des libertés il revient en
permanence en débat depuis le début de
cette mandature les libertés publiques
les libertés individuelles n'ont cessé
d'être abaissée ça avait commencé avec
la loi sur l'état d'urgence de juin
juillet 2010 est où on avait inscrit
dans le marbre de la loi dans le droit
commun des dispositions exceptionnelles
qui était lié à l'état d'urgence lié au
problème terroriste
on avait à l'époque indiqué que c'était
un dispositif de précaution au moment
des consultations nationales
mais contre toute attente on s'est
empressé de mettre dans ce dans le droit
commun des dispositions exceptionnelles
et puis je reviendrai rapidement sur la
dernière en date celle qui s'annonce
c'est à dire la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire dans sa version soft
dirais-je pour restreindre les libertés
encore individuel jusqu'au mois de
novembre prochain
donc je pense que cette dérive qui est
dénoncé par beaucoup d'organisations de
droits de l'homme beaucoup que le
citoyen dénote quelque part une
l'inquiétude chez de nombreux
l'individu on a vu que l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avait notamment freiné
énormément de dispositions de sécurité
notamment le dire justice
et là on s'aperçoit qu'on a encore
partie sur un dispositif donc il me fait
dire que nous sommes face aujourd'hui à
un état d'urgence permanent elles n'ont
pas sali le miso répond c'est un enjeu à
une question qui est très difficile de
faire la balance est de trouver cet
équilibre entre la question des libertés
individuelles
et puis la question de la sécurité des
français qu'elle soit sanitaires ou
qu'elle soit au sens on la connaît
habituellement et je sais parfaitement
que jean michel clément est très engagé
sur ces sujets-là la commission des lois
depuis depuis très longtemps et je pense
que ce débat est toujours légitime et
c'est normal qu'il y ait des
associations des citoyens des
parlementaires qu'ils soient vigilants
et qui alertent moi je vous dis ma
conviction en tant que membre du
gouvernement et membre de cette majorité
c'est qu'on a cette recherche permanente
d'un équilibre qui nous permet de ne pas
rompre avec les libertés individuelles
évidemment que la situation sanitaire
qu'on connaît et que les mesures qui ont
été prises avec un confinement ce qui
est pour moi la restriction de liberté
ultime puisqu'on vous empêchent de
circuler autrement qu'avec une ça ne
peut pas durer une attestation ça peut
pas durer évidemment non l'état
d'urgence sanitaire ça peut pas durer
non plus mais évidemment non on s'adapte
à une situation sanitaire qui par
principe évolué qui par principe et
changeante sur une pathologie pour
laquelle on apprend des choses chaque
jour nouvelle est évidemment c'est pas
de gaîté de coeur quand on prend des
mesures qui visent à ces retards et à
restreindre certaines libertés mais on
le fait pour protéger les français et on
a vu les études qui ont été faites à
propos du confinement qui ont montré que
c'est des centaines de milliers de vies
qui avait été sauvée grâce au
confinement
on voit la nécessité alors en ces
mesures cédric perrin vous vous avez une
question à poser au tour on en a parlé
un petit peu au tout début des forces de
l'ordre et de la stigmatisation vous
dites de la police vous tv l'émission
miss bonjour bonsoir plus tôt moi
j'aimerais d'abord
aborder une question de cette question
évidemment de kinki nous nous qui moi me
touche beaucoup évidemment c'est de la
police j'ai commencé par une précision
lexical qui mérite sans doute d'être
rappelé je m'étonne d'ailleurs que que
le ministre ou quelqu'un ministre en
tout cas n'en fasse n'en fasse état
c'est l'expression de violences
policières
pour moi cette expression n'a pas de
sens parce que les forces de police sont
usage d'une force qui est une force
légitime et qui doit être bien entendu
sanctionner si par l'autorité judiciaire
si possible des fautes devait être
commises et donc pour moi la force de
rester à la loi
et aucune profession quelque chose soit
claire n'est malheureusement
irréprochable et il ya sans doute dans
la police comme ailleurs des gens qui
doivent être sanctionnés pour des fautes
de racisme et c'est une évidence absolue
mais pour autant un ministre de la
république premier flic de france de
surcroît n'a pas à stigmatiser
l'ensemble d'une profession mise très
misa les muses durement à l'épreuve ces
sept dernières années et les forces de
l'ordre mais il mérite sans aucun autre
notre considération et notre respect et
la non plus l'amalgamme n'est pas n'est
pas n'a pas sa place que dit elle
s'exprime je voudrais surtout savoir
parce que je pense que les ministres ont
fait des fautes pour moi absolument
irresponsables l'un en plaçant l'émotion
au dessus de la loi et l'autre je parle
de la mise de la justice en intervenant
dans une affaire individuelle en
piétinant la séparation des pouvoirs et
j'aimerais savoir comment vous comptez
monsieur le ministre
restauré en tout cas le lien de
confiance entre nos citoyens nos
concitoyens et les forces de l'ordre
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental à un moment où les
radicalistes lady colonise des coloniaux
les indigéniste et c'est une question
idéologique haineuse et qui veulent
remettre en cause notre histoire
alors la question est posée comment vous
rétablissez le lien mois sur la première
partie de votre intervention je vous
rejoins totalement et d'ailleurs il m'a
été reproché par des parlementaires d'un
autre bord politique d'avoir dit que je
ne me reconnaissais pas dans le terme de
violence policière parce qu'ils laissent
penser que l'institution policière
serait par pratiques violentes qu'il y
aurait des ouïes institutionnalisé de la
violence contre les citoyens par la
police et je me rejoint je vous rejoins
quand vous dites qui peut y avoir des
dérapages comme dans toute organisation
collective qu'il faut les sanctionner
qu'il faut les condamner et comment on
rétablit le lien entre la police et la
population
moi je crois profondément au dialogue
jeu
ce qu'il faut que les gens se parlent et
je pense qu'il faut qu'ils se parlent au
niveau local et quand je me suis engagé
avec emmanuel macron en 2016 je me suis
engagé derrière son programme et dans
son programme il y avait une mesure qui
me semble très important très forte que
la police de sécurité du quotidien qui
vise à remettre des forces de l'ordre
sur le terrain dans des quartiers on
sait qu'il ya une situation difficile
qui vise évidemment assurer la
tranquillité publique et à intervenir
mais qui vise aussi à renforcer le lien
et le dial le lien et le dialogue police
population que vous que vous évoquez est
peut-être et là je l'assumé peut-être
qu'on n'a pas été assez loin assez vite
assez fort sur cette police de sécurité
du quotidien et moi je suis convaincu
que ça peut être un outil de dialogue et
avec l'allié d'hier c'est l'expérience
rapidement je n'aimerais on vous êtes
totalement dans le vrai on est
entièrement d'accord le problème c'est
qu'entre les actes et les faits il ya
une grande différence quand quand le
ministre l'intérieur prononce les mots
qu'il a prononcés on ne peut pas
vraiment dire qu'on soit dans une
volonté de dialogue via je répondre là
dessus moi j'ai écouté l'intervention de
christophe castaner il n'y avait pas de
stigmatisation des policiers il a dit ce
que vous venez de dire c'est à dire
qu'il pouvait y avoir des dérapages
comme dans toute organisation et qu'il
fallait les sanctionner qu'il fallait
être d'une fermeté absolue avec ces cas
la sfl a mais il a rappelé que ça
n'était pas le ferrailleur voilà la
police comment ce sujet l'on va
retrouver jean michel clément parce que
jean michel clément il voudrait vous
interroger sur un sujet qu'on a déjà
évoqué c'est le rsa jeunes parce que ça
c'est un sujet qui vous tient à coeur
jean miche à quai oui tout à l'heure
j'ai écouté celui je vous ai entendu
dire on ne veut pas créer des rsa jeunes
parce qu'on veut pas créer un impôt
supplémentaire
je crois que les circonstances sont tout
à fait différente aujourd'hui
moi ce qui me préoccupe par rapport aux
jeunes ou leurs sept cent mille jeunes
qui vont arriver sur le marché d'emploi
à la rentrée ces jeunes qui vont se
retrouver on leur dit on voit bien
aujourd'hui avec un déchaumeur à plus de
10 12% peut-être se dire que les
perspectives d'emploi pour eux sont très
loin les lignes de brison s'éloigne
à 25 ans lorsqu'on on rentre sur le
marché du travail
on a effectivement parfois et travailler
un peu parce que on a été peut-être
étudiants tout en travaillant c'était
mon cas c'est le cas malheureusement 2,3
au nombre de jeunes aujourd'hui ils sont
obligés de travailler pour se payer des
études mais par contre pour avoir les
deux années nécessaires pour toucher le
rsa
et bien c'est compliqué vous le savez
bien donc là aujourd'hui plus on va
retarder l'entrée dans l'emploi moins on
aura deux possibilités
effectivement d'avoir ces deux années et
2 on a des jeunes de plus en plus une
cohorte de jeunes de plus en plus
importants qu'ils ne pourront pas avoir
le rsa
donc moi je dis aujourd'hui eux mettons
de côté toutes les dispositifs toutes
les réflexions d hier et regardons la
réalité et accordant à ces jeunes il ya
treize organisations de jeunesse qui le
demandent et ça change et d'écouté des
rues la tête vous n'écoutez pas les
oreilles n'est pas si vous savez lorsque
vous je serai avec la présidente de
l'unef dans mon bureau mercredi j'étais
que la présidente de la fage qui est
notre organisation étudiante la semaine
dernière je rencontre ceux qui veulent
me rencontrer et je les ai jean michel
clément il pointait du doigt quand même
les terres de l'accès au rsa qui sont
très les gens complètement le débat moi
d'abord ce que je veux dire c'est que on
ne démissionnera pas de notre ambition
de donner des perspectives d'emploi où
je la voulais compris cette année je
pense qu'il faut assouplir les critères
du rsi vous dire parfois on a
l'impression en entendant certaines
interventions que finalement il n'y
aurait aucune perspective quoi qu'il
arrive pour aucun jeune cette année ça
n'est pas vrai et c'est important aussi
pour l'état d'esprit des jeunes pour
leur confiance de d'insister sur le fait
que là si on est en train de se
mobiliser c'est précisément pour qu'ils
aient des opportunités en matière n'ont
pas je me suis entouré du lot quelques
morceaux de l'aérien quand on sauve
l'automobile j'entends quand on sauve le
talent est ce qu'il faut connaître ça
c'est prévoir les critères d'attribution
du rsa qui sont stricts moi je vous ai
donné ma position pour ce qui est du
court terme aujourd'hui une réflexion
plus large sur le revenu universel et
d'activités c'est pas juste généralisée
c'est assouplir les critères
d'attribution de lady je privilégie
d'autres pistes que le rsa pour les
moins de 25 ans qui permettent de
conjuguer un accompagnement financier si
c'est nécessaire avec le même montant
que le rsa et qui permettent d'y
adjoindre un vrai accompagnement
humains des contreparties pour que les
jeunes bénéficient d'expérience qui leur
sont utiles ensuite pour s'insérer dont
jean michel clément qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça en deux mots bah écoutez
on connaît le discours mais sincèrement
je ne peux pas accepter quand dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles comme
celle ci alors qu'on sait je donne
rendez vous dans un an pour voir que mon
or de plus en plus de jeunes qui seront
concernés par ce dispositif
donc est ce qu'on leur donne que
perspective aujourd'hui aucune je crois
que il ya la double peine d'un côté
l'emploi qui va être retardée et d'autre
part le rsa auquel et pierre pas accéder
alors à promet aux ja oui oui à une
situation exceptionnelle et c'est pour
ça qu'ils aient une mobilisation
exceptionnelle et qu'on a commencé à le
faire sur les différents secteurs
d'activité et qu'on va continuer à le
faire avec un plan global pour les
jeunes
et là je peux vous dire qu'en termes de
perspectives il y en aura bon on verra
ça vous parliez d'apprentissage tout à
l'heure cédric perrin voudrais vous
poser une question sur l'apprentissage
parce qu'il est dans une situation
particulière dans le territoire de
belfort
oui oui je vous parle de l'apprentissage
mais je voudrais juste quand même dire
que si ce que veulent nos jeunes ce sont
des emplois et pas de l'assistanat bien
si la solution équivalent fellows et là
autrement on va pas aimer
l'apprentissage c'est pas vraiment ce
que moi je cherche non plus et je pense
que l'offre suis d'accord avec la
ministre de l'apprentissage machine mais
je la vis une région frontalière
évidemment je suis sénateur d'un
département frontalier de la suisse est
depuis plusieurs années j'essaie de me
battre pour que nos jeunes français
puissent faire leur apprentissage en
suis en suisse je m'explique canton du
jura suisse 2 % de chômage
évidemment l'horlogerie est un sujet
majeur à la frontière suisse est une
entreprise bien connue qui embauchent
plus de 700 personnes sur les 700 il y
en a quatre
quasiment 80 % qui sont sales français
mais 100 % des apprentis sont suisses et
aujourd'hui si nous ne faisons rien et
si une personne pendant capacité
d'offrir aux suisses la possibilité de
trouver de la main d'oeuvre bien les
entreprises partiront parce qu'elles ne
trouveront pas suffisamment de manoeuvre
le plein emploi est quasiment eu pour
l'instant existants comment est ce qu'on
peut faire pour trouver une solution
pour que nous puissions conventionnés
avec nos voisins suisses pour que nos
jeunes puissent aller faire leur
apprentissage en suisse il trouve du
travail parce qu'il y en a et
aujourd'hui on est bloqué pour des
raisons administratives pour des raisons
souvent de normes
à ne pas pouvoir donner des emplois aux
jeunes à l'horizon
oui c'est une question très précise je
connais pas spécifiquement la situation
à laquelle vous faites référence mais ce
que vous dites me semble frappée du bon
sens que permettre à des jeunes d'aller
saisir des opportunités en matière
d'apprentissage et peut-être ensuite en
matière d'emploi de l'autre côté de la
frontière ça me semble absolument
absolument nécessaire et justifiée donc
moi je peux m'engager à en parler avec
mes collègues ça concerne à la fois le
ministère du travail et puis le quai
d'orsay puisqu'il ya un enjeu
il ya un enjeu transfrontalier et puis à
ce qu'on revienne vers vous pour voir
comment faire avancer cette fois soupire
vous le dis vous dites vous pensez qu'il
faut assouplir quand même séance de
réglementations qui empêchent les
français d'aller se former ainsi si
comme vous le dites il ya des blocages
qui sont purement administratif les
choses peuvent se se débloquer jean
michel perrin et ses lecteurs à paris
écoutez le recteur de le recteur de
bourgogne franche comté parfaitement au
courant de la situation on en parle
souvent ensemble ils essaient de trouver
des solutions mais je peux vous assurer
c'est compliqué moi je suis prêt a
vraiment aimé travailler avec vous parce
qu'il ya un enjeu majeur et l'entretien
ouais là qui a pris un engagement devant
vous donc on a beaucoup développer
l'apprentissage avec l'allemagne est
sans doute qu'il faut le faire davantage
avec la suisse est sauf que la suisse
n'avait de l'union européenne seulement
jeu c'est un problème peut-être bas on
va y travailler
bon jean michel clément par l'ong
rossouw maintenant avec vous et rapide
mais un parent ressources et le temps
voilà l'état moi je voudrais vous
interroger sur la votre vision de savoir
comment on va combler demain ce déficit
qui s'annonce et comment on va faire
face à l'urgence on lit un débat qui
s'est ouvert sur un isf est exceptionnel
dans plusieurs pays européens
en allemagne par exemple mais également
en angleterre en espagne on parle d'un
impôt de solidarité sur la fortune en
france liées à sa fin et il est venu
dans les conditions que vous savez au
profit de qui vous savez aussi
moi je m'interroge sur le fait de savoir
si les
le rétablissement de l'hymne sf avec un
double objectif de justice sociale mais
aussi de justice climatique parce qu'on
pourrait parfaitement aujourd'hui aussi
ciblé le lit sf dans des pour des
objectifs bien clair moi je ne comprends
pas le discours du président de la
république qui se refuse toujours à me
remettre liés c'est alors je vous
rappelle que c'était une des
revendications fortes et gilet jaune et
pour peu il serait à mal ou le soulever
don kelly assad il ya cinq blessés moi
j'ai su permettrait de financer des
choses précises l'environnement par
exemple
moi j'assume parfaitement la suppression
de l' isf qui était je le rappelle un
programme du président de la république
et de la majorité présidentielle pour
laquelle j'ai fait campagne comme jean
michel clément d'ailleurs à à l'époque
il y avait une clarté absolue là dessus
pour les candidats que nous étions la
république en marche au moment des
élections législatives moi je ne suis
pas pour les mesures symboliques
c'est pas symbolique c'est
d'investissement et vous savez le lit sf
quand il existait rapporter 3 milliards
d'euros je crois le président de la
république a rappelé hier les chiffres
qui ont été engagées dans le cadre de
cette crise je crois que c'est autour de
500 milliards d'euros
on voit bien que rétablir lisf ne
permettra pas de financer demandant le
dixième des mesures qui sont nécessaires
jean-michel clients vous parler de la
question d'investissements ciblés wim et
donc lavées donc la question
donc la question devient une question
d'ordre symbolique et moi je pense que
les symboles ont beaucoup coûté à la
france en termes d'attractivité jeunes
champions en battant des goûters
aujourd'hui tous les pays tous les pays
développés se préoccupe de taxer les
plus riches
très concrètement on a taxé co
l'immobilier on a écarté toute la sienne
mobilières détaxation dont on sait que
c'est ce qui constitue le patrimoine le
plus important je crois que dans cette
démarche aujourd'hui rétablir lisf dès
lors qu'on veut on nous dit aussi que si
on le fait en france ils vont fuir
ailleurs et fuir ailleurs si les algues
utilisées d'anglais civils américains
s'y mêle si également les allemands s'y
mettent
ils vont rester chez nous et on est
extra et en le ciblant on a tout intérêt
bien aujourd'hui avec que tout le monde
met la main à la responsabilité
un mot rapide la france est déjà un pays
c'est un pays qui a déjà le niveau de
pression fiscale le plus un des plus
élevés même si heureusement ils baissent
depuis trois ans peut-être que certains
pays met en place une fiscalité
supplémentaire je suis pas sûr que ça
leur permet d'arriver à notre niveau en
la matière ils étaient encore une fois
j'assume cette décision qui a été prise
je considère que de l'argent qui a
investi dans le capital de nos
entreprises qui permet l'investît à
l'heure dans l'économie productive c'est
de l'argent avec nous investir c'est la
question que vous vous posez cédric
perrin oui moi monsieur lune et je suis
je suis présent la commission de la
défense et et rapporteur de ce qu'on
appelle le pays 146 les fameuses
équipements des forces qui représente je
le rappelle n'est je pense que
l'essentiel des titres nos auditeurs ne
le savent pas deux tiers du budget
d'investissement de l'état saviez tout 6
milliards d'euros et je pense que une
relance keynésienne si tant est qu'on
puisse l'appeler comme ça a plutôt fade
parfois tendance à relancer l'économie
dans des pays dans des pays tiers
et est ce que le sujet qui consisterait
à accélérer la loi de programmation
militaire et à investir massivement
justement dans la dans la baie de t d
dans la base industrielle et
technologique de référence donc sur des
entreprises non délocalisables quelque
chose qui qui elle dans l'est dans les
tuyaux je pense que c'est très important
il s'appelle là qu'il arrive alors ce
qui est dans les tuyaux c'est une vraie
relance par l'investissement dans des
secteurs clés président de la république
a notamment hier à bord d un secteur qui
est celui de la rénovation énergie est
ce que la défense est un secteur clé du
bâtiment mais ça l'est déjà depuis 2010
est vous êtes membre de la commission de
la défense donc vous savez à quel point
nous investissons dans le secteur de la
défense
le budget qui augmente le plus en 2020
c'est celui de la défense est un
objectif qui a été fixé par le président
de la république c'est d'arriver à 2% du
pib pour les dépenses de défense en 2025
je crois que ça augmente de 1,7 milliard
d'euros chaque année
c'est bien je ne me trompe pas et c'est
un c'est un investissement qui est
supérieur à celui de tous les
gouvernements qui nous ont précédés
voilà évidemment va poursuivre dans
cette trajectoire et je vous rejoins sur
le fait que c'est très important
voilà pour la réponse merci en tout cas
c'est à y perdre 1 jean michel clément
d'avoir été avec nous en duplex pour
audition publique place maintenant à
yves thréard du figaro
[Musique]
c'est le regard distrait rebond soir
yves bonsoir francis bonsoir monsieur le
ministre en soi alors vous avez écouté
le président de la république icr
j'imagine comme quelque 22 millions de
français et il nous a dit que et bien
victoire on avait gagné la partie contre
le coronavirus il y avait comme beaucoup
d'autosatisfaction d'ailleurs ça a été
remarqué par beaucoup de téléspectateurs
qui ont trouvé qu'il en faisait beaucoup
vous savez moi j'ai trouvé un président
très lucide il a dîné pamart ce test on
a on a perdu
il a redit ce qu'il avait déjà dit dans
sa présente l'intervention c'est à dire
qu'il nous faudra tirer les
enseignements de cette crise sur ce qui
a fonctionné et ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné et dans une précédente
intervention il avait même dit et mis
des mots sur le fait qu'il y a des
choses qui n'avait pas fonctionné
notamment les masques vous avez d'accord
là dessus il ya une une lucidité une
nécessité absolue et des enseignements
seront attirés maintenant moi je pense
qu'il est nécessaire de se rendre compte
et de mesurer que la france est un des
pays qui a le mieux protégé en terme
social en termes financiers en termes
d'emploi ça se paiera fnsa qu'elle
rihanna talent ça va coûter une fortune
on est le pays qui a le plus dépensé
justement à juste titre peut-être pour
venir en aide aux français quelles que
soient leur âge leur condition sociale
mais vous reconnaîtrez que d'autres pays
qui étaient équipés qui ont su anticiper
qui ont pas dit que c'était pas utile de
porter un masque
ils ont traversé cette crise en
continuant à les travailler pour
beaucoup d'entre eux je pense à la corée
du sud un peu à l'allemagne et qui s'en
tire avec un bilan sanitaire que pas
mauvais et enfin meilleur que le nôtre
et peut-être avec des dépenses publiques
qui sont un peu inférieurs je crois que
vous savez sur la question des
équipements il ya eu des tensions dans
l'essentiel si ce n'est tous les pays y
compris dans les pays que vous avez
cités notamment en allemagne
encore une fois président a été très
lucide sur le fait qu'il ya des choses
qui n'ont pas fonctionné qu'on en tirera
des enseignements mais je pense qu'il
faut essayer dé l'histoire vous auriez
employer ce mot là comment victoire vous
l'auriez employés mais aujourd'hui on
voit que gros de l'épidémie
derrière nous qu'on a réussi à garantir
que tous les patients qui avaient besoin
d'être accueillis dans un service de
réanimation ont pu l'être ou sonner
c'est la fameuse courbe où il ne fallait
pas dépasser la capacité de réanimation
cet objectif là il a été tenu maintenant
encore une fois est-ce que tout a été
réussie évidemment non mais alors les
enseignements sont rechute on nous dans
l'avenir il nous a fait une dissertation
hier avec de grands mots qui ronfle bien
d'ailleurs souveraineté il faut
recouvrir notre souveraineté avec
dépendances dépendance avec solidaires
écologie est un un mot assez
intéressante décentralisation est ce que
d'après vous il faut un nouvel acte de
décentralisation en france sachant qu'il
ya eu 2 de gaulle avait organisé la
france et puis mitterrand et de fer ont
lancé une deuxième décentralisation est
ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
oui je crois qu'il y avait un élément
très fort dans le discours du président
de la république hier qui résonne
beaucoup avec cette crise qui est de
donner plus de capacité d'initiative et
de liberté on est trop attention le
terrain il a dit tout ne peut pas être
décidées depuis paris il y avait bien
lui dis je puis jupiter et vous savez on
a tous appris pendant cette crise le
président l'a dit il faut se réinventer
mais c'est de cet cet objectif de donner
plus de capacité d'initiative au terrain
qui nous anime depuis le début du
quinquennat compris dans l'éducation
vous savez on a présenté un projet de
loi préparé un projet de loi qui
s'appelle 3d avec
les entre anisation on a voulu tellement
compliqué tout ça que persuadé qu'on a
mais pourtant ça et puis la journée
spéciale la copie et on a voulu et on a
voulu mettre en place une mesure de
différenciation qui permet sur le
territoire d'avoir des initiatives y
compris qui déroge à déréglementer fois
les prévoir le niveau national oui je le
prends le compris dans les voiles de
résiliation le président de la
république a cité les cols comme un des
secteurs dans lequel on peut des
programmes différents d'une région à une
autre loin je pense pas sur la question
des programmes et peut-être sur la
question de l'autonomie de la capacité
de recrutement des alliances et des
débats qui se regardent l'autonomie qui
pourrait accorder aux hôpitaux parce
qu'on a vu que les hôpitaux aussi
fallait peut-être qu'ils vont qu'ils
aient davantage des coûteux que des
d'autonomie ça peut être pareil pour les
enseignes les établissements ce que je
vous dis c'est que le président de la
république hier a dit qu'il fallait
donner plus de marge de manoeuvre et
plus de capacité d'initiative au terrain
qu'il a cité plusieurs exemples les
hôpitaux et les écoles et qu'on va avoir
un débat et un travail autour de la
sueur les écoles est ce que ça on le
saura
lorsqu'il prendra la parole au début du
mois de juillet oui je pense que dans
l'intervention du président de la rép ça
sera plus détaillée parce que là c'est
n'ira plus que de la gare go il a tandis
que ça sera plus de détails et je pense
que c'était important qu'ils s'expriment
ce dimanche d'abord pour parler de la
dernière étape du déconfinement du 22
juin et puis pour commencer à donner des
pistes sur les travaux qui vont être
engagées mais évidemment début juillet
début dans le courant du mois de juillet
comme il a dit il y aura une
intervention courant du mois de juillet
est ce que il y aura un remaniement
avant oui il y aura un remaniement sans
doute à sa part principe tout c'est que
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
puisque je ne suis pas du tout revanche
il que sur laquelle m 2 de cette
question là c'est le président et
premier ministre qui décide du
romanesque que vous être un ministre
heureux je suis heureux de faire ce que
je fais au quotidien
est ce que vous voudriez prendre du
galon voir vos compétences s'élargir à
la faveur d'un remaniement alors vous
savez vous allez peut-être pas me croire
mais j'ai 31 ans je suis en vo croit la
job j'ai 31 ans et je suis membre du
gouvernement de mon pays
chaque jour je mesure vous étonnez
maintenant mais je mesure la chance qui
est la mienne d'avoir ses
responsabilités et la responsabilité par
ailleurs ce que ça nécessite d'être au
niveau d'être à la hauteur je fais au
mieux pour y parvenir mais je suis pas
là à me dire comment est ce que je vais
faire pour changer quoi que ce soit
alors je vais vous donner une petite
piste je vous donne le choix ça marche
pas très fort le groupe la république en
marche à l'assemblée nationale si on en
croit tous qui tout ce qu'on entend tout
ce qu'on dit ou ce qu'on écrit tout ce
qu'on lit ça où ça pourrait vous tentez
vous diriger le groupe puisque le
président du groupe monsieur legendre a
l'air assez contesté est ce que ça vous
dirait de diriger le groupe à
l'assemblée nationale de la république
en marche
il ya un président de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale qui est gilles
legendre n'ai pas de raison de changer
et il n'y a pas de raison pour moi de me
prononcer sur ce sujet là ça relève des
parlementaires de la vie du groupe g
était parlementaire au début de ce
quinquennat
et si un ministre était venu depuis le
gouvernement donner des leçons sur le
fonctionnement du groupe et dans des
positions comme celle-là je leur ai
assez mal mais les dans l'absolu entre
présidents de groupe et secrétaires
d'état
bush maintenant mais j'en juge et ya pas
de choix à faire puisque d'abord le
choix des secrétaires d'état ne
m'appartient pas ensuite la question du
groupe ne se pose pas puisque un
président de groupe qui est gilles
legendre qui fait un travail qui est
difficile parce que c'est difficile de
gérer un groupe majoritaire ça l'a
toujours été dans toutes les majorités
on est dans un moment où le pays
traverse une crise et que par principe
saad et déraisonné alors que sa lettre
il est parfaitement légitime pour un
président du groupe majoritaire
d'envoyer des messages des propositions
des notes président de l'arrivée quand
on oublie premier ministre dans son
courrier en disant bon il faudrait
peut-être le changer moi je rentre pas
dans les détails je considère que une
correspondance qui est privé devrait pas
y avoir accès au pardon j'ai pas de
commentaire oui mais je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire sur ce sujet
dernière question et servir à des jeunes
qui seront place de la concorde au 14
juillet puisqu'on sait qu'il y aura 2500
à 3000 personnes je crois seulement est
ce que cette jeunesse dont nous vous et
dès que vous représentez d'une certaine
façon vous êtes jeunes aussi elle sera
présent d'une façon ou d'une autre à
cette occasion bien sûr parce que la vie
ce délai les enfants enfin les enfants
les jeunes les jeunes du service
universel
vous savez moi le
l'an dernier c'était une très grande et
belle satisfaction pour moi de voir les
jeunes du service national universel
défilé au xiv y seront de nouveau c'est
à dire un très beau et très belle
marquez des lits seront de nouveau moi
je souhaite qu'il puisse participer
d'une manière ou d'une autre à cette
cérémonie mais vous savez ça peut être
aussi pour aider à l'organisation pour
aider très concrètement à la cérémonie
de se tenir c'est ce que les jeunes du
hassania ont fait l'an dernier
d'ailleurs il avait aidé à
l'organisation et je pense que c'est
important aussi pour célébrer cette
jeunesse qui s'engage comme les services
des jeunes du service civique qui soit
aussi très engagé qui peuvent être mis à
l'honneur
on sait que le personnel hospitalier a
bénéficié ou recevoir des primes est ce
que les jeunes qui au 16e universelle
qui ont servi dans les services
hospitaliers pendant la crise du lait
zidane est ce que eux aussi vont avoir
une prime il y avait des jeunes du
service civique non pas dans les
services hospitaliers mais qui avait une
mission les ai pas dans les ehpad
par exemple ce qu'ils ont une prime
c'est des jeunes qui se sont engagés en
service civique parce qu'ils avaient
envie de s'engager pour un laurent pas
d'autres images aléas raciale
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est pas à
l'ordre du jour a prévu mais ça n'a pas
été demandé non plus encore une fois ils
se sont engagés ou en choisissant cette
mission d'ailleurs avant le confinement
ils l'ont mené pendant le confinement
avec beaucoup de détermination et je
veux vraiment à saluer leur mobilisation
merci merci pour ces questions
supplémentaires notamment le 14 juillet
qui nous avait échappé
c'est la fin d'audition publique et
briatte al merci d'avoir accepté de
débattre est de répondre à nos questions
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur figaro live ainsi que
sur les comptes twitter de lcp et public
sénat et auditions publiques revient
évidemment lundi en direct à 19h bonne
soirée
non
[Musique]